good afternoon everyone by way of a
background I'd like to give you a little
bit of a context
most people who have approached cancer
immunotherapy today have not come from
that field but come from outside this is
a very hot area of the field of research
and it's actually the oldest area of
Cancer Research stemming back to the
1800s where the roots of cancer
immunology began with the father of
cellular pathology Rudi Vercoe who first
described cancer as an inflammation that
was burnt and present beyond the point
at which a wound would heal Berko as you
know was the father of the notion that
disease starts in cells and he was also
the man who gave the first idea around
cancer as a problem of inflammation and
immune system subsequently later in the
19th century Paul Ehrlich was the first
to enunciate the idea of immune
surveillance that the immune system
could control cancer and some of the
early work done by Coley in the US and
others around the world showed that by
manipulating the immune system with
infectious agents using bacterial toxins
basically patients could show effects on
the immune system that were correlated
with cancer responses even the
eradication of metastatic disease in
some patients so this aspect of cancer
is very old it was joined by other
threads the most dominant of course
became the thread that led to cancer
genetics the roots of that field in the
1900s came from studies of animal tumor
viruses by raus tissue culture studies
later by Eagle set of genetics by Noel
and Hungerford also at the Fox chase
these studies became dominant eventually
starting around 1980 with the discovery
of oncogenes I think a big event that is
not widely appreciated that separated
these two traditions was in the 1970s
with the discovery of immunodeficient
animals particularly the nude mouse that
could support the growth of human tumors
within the mouse this is a mouse that
had an aberrant immune system to that
extent did not reject a human tissue
these mice were interesting partly
because they don't have a higher
incidence of
spontaneous cancer on their own compared
to normal mice and the discoverers of
these mice thought that was a very
important feature and in fact this
became the root of an argument that said
the immune system was not important to
cancer you could destroy it in an animal
to the degree that wouldn't reject the
human tissue it would support the growth
of human tumors this led to the
xenograph tradition and discovery of new
cancer drugs and the thinking here was
that the modern cancer researchers could
ignore the immune system and I call that
the divorce the separation of cancer
genetics which became dominant course in
our field starting about 1980 the cancer
immunologists were sort of sent into the
wilderness to some degree and this is a
tradition that continued and it was not
until really about 2000 when
sophisticated knockout mutant animals
were made they caused what I call the
remarriage the realization by the
mainstream of the field that immunology
is really important and that the immune
system is an important suppressor of
cancer maybe one of the most important
if not the most important and the nature
of these experiments were from knockouts
of the stat transcription factors that
mediate signals from interference also
interferon knockouts that showed that
mice lacking these genes had very high
rates of spontaneous cancer the problem
of course was a nude Mouse's we didn't
know about natural killer cells back
then which were still active in nude
mice and maintained their normal rates
of spontaneous cancer but it wasn't
until 2000 that this remarriage brought
the mainstream to the realization that
we all have to pay attention to
immunology over the last decade there's
been a conceptual synthesis and it comes
between the two different worlds that
really were brought together in part
also by studies of inflammation so those
studying genes realize that in the
tissue
if inflammatory signals weren't present
these cancer-causing genes were rather
impotent and that was a realization that
happened I would say starting around
2000 and dumb tailed nicely with the
demonstrations that the immune system is
a key suppressor so coming from two
lines of work the xenograph tradition
cancer genetics for targeted therapy we
have now modern cancer cell centric
therapy may be added by efforts to get a
cancer stem
today and we have host centric therapy
that's gotten a lift from the work on
angiogenesis but also more recently in
immunology and putting those two
together these where amino chemotherapy
comes in the idea of treating the host
immune system plus the existing
treatments of chemotherapy and
traditional radiotherapy and surgery
what exactly is cancer this is a also an
old idea that comes anew as a result of
some of the new information you will
hear about and become familiar with not
only the level of causality but
treatment our modern theory today of
course is that the rogue cells of cancer
are created by cancer inducing molecules
and our modern therapies attack those
molecules for example by taking the EGF
receptor by Erbitux for example there is
an established trend in attacking the
microenvironment this is now part of the
mainstream and been demonstrated most
dramatically perhaps clinically by the
success of attacking microenvironment
and support molecules that have to do
with angiogenesis the attraction of a
blood supply by a tumor so ante veg F
antibodies such as Avastin do that the
new emerging idea of course which has
taken the field by storm I would say the
last three to five years now is the
notion that immune escaped licenses
outgrowth of Burgh cells and all cancer
cells must learn how somehow evolved the
capability to escape the immune system
and therapies that attack escape
mechanisms they restore immune of
control and be effective so the first
example this is of course anti ctla4 or
your boy the antibody that resets the
self non-self tolerance mechanisms in
the body to restore what would otherwise
be a tolerance and it's to move to our
attack on cancer now the deep idea in
immunology for over 100 years has really
been that maybe the clinical phenomenon
of cancer is more than just rogue cells
but rather a clinical problem of loss of
control certainly by the age of 50
someone like me or even older as you get
into men that are in their 60s and 70s
it's very easy to find prostate cancer
the notion that dormant cancers exist in
the elderly at subclinical levels that
are not found or only found
serendipitously during surgery for
unrelated
situations that the the problem is not
so much that you have cancer cells in
you but that your body has lost the
ability to manage them and the cancer
might arise from the problem of the loss
of control that that's the clinical
phenomenon that's the big idea at the
root of immunotherapy and marrying that
to the attack of the rogue cells which
is what modern established trends in our
field do is what immuno chemotherapy is
all about immune escape that concept as
part of the traits of cancer popularized
by this figure taken from reviews by
Hanahan and Weinberg over the years and
so this is a new part of the pie if you
like in 2000 when Hanahan and Weinberg
first published this notion of different
traits of cancer that cancer cells must
acquire this was a part of the pie that
was missing as I say it wasn't part of
the mainstream by 2010 it had become
part of the mainstream and it now
appears that many of the mechanisms that
licensed the escape of immune system are
also tied into metastasis invasion
angiogenesis and metabolic now the
theory of how immune escape evolves in
the tumor microenvironment has been if
you like attached as a veneer a
conceptual veneer atop the dominant
theory of cancer which has to do with
oncogenesis and the attack juez ition of
mutated or miss regulated genes in that
theory of oncogenesis which is
popularized by vogelstein and others in
the late 80s and early 90s the normal
cell is transformed to a more cancerous
state as a result of the acquisition of
genetic mutations also epigenetic
changes in that cell can transform it
the immune system which is very
sensitive to changes in structure of
self can detect those and eliminate them
but as a result of that selection given
the transformed plastic state of what
might be a very small colony that's
dynamic and regulated there is the
possibility for evolution as a result of
the selective pressure applied by the
immune surveillance immune cells that
selection which is a fundamental aspect
of cancer and its main challenge the
selection for resistance
and lead to an equilibrium state where
occult tumors may persist in a dynamic
form that are again regulated but not
eliminated this equilibrium state has
been demonstrated in animals by Bob
Schreiber and it correlates it's been
suggested to this phenomenon of tumor
dormancy a clinical phenomenon that
surgeons have noted for years this was a
controversial area itself until the late
1990s when it was shown that cured
cancer patients could still sustain
cancers in their system that were
actually obtained from organ transplant
so the organ transplant recipient would
come down with a cancer it could be
shown genetically that that cancer
actually came from the donor even though
the recipient had been cancer-free for
15 years after the transplant so this
notion of an occult tumor that can
persist and do present but not be a
clinical problem has been proven in
humans as well as in mice now with
further iteration of selection for
immune resistance various mechanisms
that are selected eventually you might
achieve a state known as escape and this
would be the state at which the dynamic
dynamic but dormant tumor then can begin
to get on top of the host gradually the
seesaw begins to tilt to such a state
that it's possible for malignant cells
to begin to accumulate and form a
clinically detectable problem initially
locally but ultimately in the
disseminated form the modifiers in micro
environment are very critical to the
late stages of this process the
crosstalk between the setting of the
tissue and the host genes that don't
necessarily drive the disease so much as
modify its outcome the bandwidth on the
internet information if you like as an
analogy here those modifier genes and
the micro environment in which that
tumor arises especially its immune micro
environment become the dominant aspects
of whether the genes that started the
story actually turned out to be that
importantly inflammation here has also
been a field in which there has been
crosstalk and I think conceptual
synthesis between different minds in the
field again the inflammatory micro
environment informs in some cases what
would be a chronic
state into an acute state that arises as
a cancer not all inflammatory lesions
for example in the GI may arise to
become colon cancer or another GI cancer
but some do and it turns out that animal
studies suggest some of the genes that
are affecting immune escape are the same
as those that are in programming the
inflammatory state in these chronic
inflammation that dictate what becomes a
cancer and what remains as a chronically
inflamed but non cancerous lesion so the
insights were obtaining from the
marriage of immuno editing this new
theory of how immune escaped evolves
with the more traditional and
established a model of oncogenesis are
leading us to these deeper insights that
immuno chemotherapy will take advantage
of so for those of you who are not in
immunology what is immunotherapy but
shortly it's those drugs or actions that
would recruit the patient's natural
immune system to fight disease the most
traditional immunotherapy of the last
century one of the glories of science
really vaccination in vaccine and
vaccines have been developed for cancer
as well a foreign agent is introduced
into the blood this would be in the case
of a tumor or a tumor antigen and there
are specialized cells that Rove the body
rather like tourists and take pictures
of what they see they keep that Energon
in hand and Rove through the bloodstream
until they come to a specialized
lymphoid organ known as a lymph node in
which lymphoid cells live and this is
where you might think of as sort of a
family gathering where pictures are
shown and certain cells respond to those
very strongly a specific recognition of
an antigen will lead to an activation of
cells t-cells and other kinds of immune
adaptive immune cells which then can
Rove into the body and destroy the free
that foreign antigen that foreign
picture that was shown in vaccination
this has proved to be very effective at
managing infectious disease there has
been a great deal of historical effort
to manage cancer in this fashion now of
course these vaccines are given to
manage disease while the disease is
present rather than prevents it
typically in the history of cancer
research at least but in considering the
principles there in immunotherapy
we've had cell based as well as
biologics that add capabilities active
immune therapy that would lead to the
generation of t-cell features either by
antigen presentation or direct
introduction of T cells that are
activated by tumor antigens we have
passive immunotherapy this has really
been where the great success of the
immunologic field has been in cancer
research the use of antibodies to attack
cancerous molecules and finally we have
immunomodulators these really modified
the existing capabilities of the host an
example of this might be inflammatory
modulator such as the cox-2 inhibitor
these are not affecting direct to
disease pathways but rather the modifier
pathways that influence whether disease
pathway produces an acute or a low level
perhaps sub clinical problem so by this
manner the immune system and through its
manipulation by therapy immunotherapy
can step on the gas effect the brake and
clutch or drive the steering wheel to
direct the immune system in different
ways and change its attitude toward
foreignness or as in the case of cancer
antigens things that are somewhat
different but still look like a lot look
much like us and that is partly the
challenge for cancer how do we tailor
immune therapy so that it attacks the
foreignness of the tumor but not so far
in that it attacks the body and that is
one of the challenges faced by the
modern immunotherapies and you'll hear
about that so active immunotherapy has
actually been around for over a hundred
years I mentioned Coley's work with
bacterial toxins these have been
modernized so that the toxin itself
rather than the bacteria is now been
studied in the last decade or so by many
entities many organizations how how has
it that this has been such a poor
project it really has been to the view
of many like myself that you know not
understanding immune escape was the
problem in the failures of active
immunotherapy really to attract
adherence there are patients that
responds historically that you've seen
but these have never been converted into
large groups that could be convincing
and the trials have tended to have
failed or barely have been able to
manage
sir partly that's because the tumor has
erected in the host so many barriers has
escaped the ability of the immune system
to modulate when you're standing on the
brick it's very hard to get on the gas
supportive informations and t-cell
tolerance treating the tumor as if it
was the self these are the things that
have made active immune therapy failed
I'm going to now turn a little bit some
of the most exciting work in the field
that it's really penetrated in the
mainstream especially on the clinical in
the clinical sphere and this takes
advantage of what have been called the
checkpoint therapies that activate
t-cell responses as many immunologists a
on the call may know APC or
antigen presenting cells talk to the
immune system
activate t-cell responses in two
fashions by showing the antigen in a
special context of a molecule called
major histocompatibility to t-cell
receptors that are specific for that and
as a result of that engagement they are
potentially activatable if a second
signal comes along that stimulates what
are called co stimulatory receptors
those two signals can trigger adaptive
immune responses the checkpoints are
really Co regulatory receptors that do
not engage the receptor in a positive
fashion but rather in a negative fashion
they tell the t-cell okay you saw your
antigen but become tolerant to it don't
become hostile to it these immune
checkpoint molecules such as ctla4 are
those that are have been attacked by the
early therapy
I want to say a little bit more about
checkpoint molecules just to point out
again give you a better picture of
what's going on in this realm where
there's so much activity in the field
the antigen-presenting cell providing a
specific antigen that a t-cell can
recognize in a certain context that is
influenced by positive and negative
regulators from signal two there's a
large variety and as I mentioned a great
deal of the work is going to involve a
focus on these molecules that are
approved as targets for immunotherapy
the amino Cameron therapy of the future
is going to have a lot of parts a lot of
moving parts it's going to involve the
destruction of the rogue tumor cells the
way we traditionally have done it with
chemotherapy and radiotherapy but also
the way we do it now with targeted
therapies that are personalized to the
mutations in the cancer but those will
be combined with checkpoint pathway
inhibitors such as your lawyer or the
pd-1 inhibitors they will be combined
with immunomodulators such as I do
inhibitors or adenosine modifier pathway
modifiers they will be used in
cooperation with adoptive cell therapies
or vaccines for example in resected
patients that receive adjuvant immuno
chemo therapy vaccination may help keep
them out of the woods longer and we'll
hear from the vaccine experts about how
prophylactic use as well as treatment
may be a part of future immuno
chemotherapy so with that I think
there's a lot of optimism for the future
this is now the end of my presentation
and I will entertain some questions from
the participants of the webinar but
before we go to that I'm going to hand
off to my colleague AB kam Karin Sharma
who will give a short presentation from
the sponsor Karen Thank You professor
for such a clear presentation I'm sure
that there will be plenty of interesting
questions at the end at this time I
would like to take just a few minutes to
highlight products and resources that we
hope will be of interest and that can
help accelerate your research AB can
simple step eliza kits are designed to
improve workflow over traditional
sandwich
simple step Eliza's use a proprietary
technology that saves time and increases
reproducibility of protein
quantification by only requiring one
wash step the entire analysis is
performed in under two hours bringing
this to 50% less assay time than the
standard Eliza a vast selection of human
and mouse analytes can be quantified
using the simple step Eliza platform
below are a few human targets that may
be of interest for researchers studying
cancer pathways or the tumor
micro-environment
our list of simple SEP Eliza's continues
to grow and to see what we currently
have available please visit us at WWF
can calm / simple send our tissue slides
and tissue microarrays are useful for
the identification and localization of
RNA or protein in both normal or
diseased state tissue samples tissue
slides are available for a range of
disease states from various organs
slides are available from a range of
species including human mouse and rat
human fetus slides are also available
slides are from formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded samples and
approximately 5 micrometers thick tissue
microarrays containing up to 228 tissue
samples per slide are also available
allowing high-throughput analysis of RNA
DNA or protein expression our
microarrays are also available from
human mouse and rat tissues tissue
arrays contain both disease states and
control course with pathology and
grading of course available in protocol
booklets IHC control arrays are also
available all tissues are fixed and 10%
neutral buffered formalin for 24 to 48
hours and cut fresh upon receipt of
order to learn more about these products
please visit www.hp.com/recycle ection
of interactive pathways designed to help
you find products which work together to
elucidate a particular pathway below are
just a few examples of the many
interactive cancer pathways that can be
found on our website
if you look at the T cell activation
interactive pathway in more detail you
can see the full signal transduction of
T cell activation
starting from stimulation of the T cell
receptor by an antigen presenting cell
all the way to the appropriate immune
response if you would like to focus on a
particular protein in the pathway such
as zap-70 simply click on the protein in
the diagram this brings up a listing of
the current zap70 products in our
catalog that can then be categorized by
the product type filter napkin has a
growing library of resources dedicated
to cancer research to view ab cams
complete collection of interactive
pathways please visit us at WWF can calm
slash interactive pathways to look for
protocols content webinars and
literature please visit us at WWF cam
comm slash cancer and if you'd like more
information and resources on the tumor
micro-environment please visit WWE to
micro if you would like to learn more or
refresh your knowledge on different
types of techniques and applications
watch our archived webinars at any time
that suits you with our online webinar
library this can be found at WWF am calm
slash webinars thank you thank you
George
and Karen for presenting today well if
you have any questions about or has been
discussed in this webinar or have any
technical inquiries our scientific
support team will be very happy to help
you and they can be contacted at
technical at öktem comm we hope you have
done this webinar informative and useful
to your work and we look forward to
welcoming you to another webinar in the
future thank you again for attending and
good luck with your research